[Music]
bro what is this about your athlete dm
oh yes so i have dms of athletes because
i'm a huge sports fan
and i dm like like mushy [ __ ] like great
game you you did
he's just a fan i mean just like such a
big fan so he's damning
none of them follow me voluntarily you
just yeah just dm yeah you're one of
those and this yeah and this is like
during while i have social media but if
it was anyone else it's fine but this is
you know he does stuff on the internet
yeah yeah true okay kind of embarrassing
okay so i have one for jack peterson he
got a groin injury oh this is so funny
when it says athlete dms i thought like
dm's from athletics
this is just dm's two athletes yeah and
no response reading it and yeah
stand behind this dude
and i love it
jack peterson
did anyone just hear that no he said
this is sad and i love it
it's sad because it's one noah's
responding which makes it worse and then
two i i don't he still doesn't know the
goal he's trying to achieve with
something i just want to like hang out i
just want to get a beer with them like
that would be my cool exactly
that's never going to happen oh my god
there's three
you triple texted
please punch in zoom in zoom in the
dates look at the dates
december you've hit him up once a year
scroll up scroll up who is this though
who is this nick bosa who's who's nick
uh
to be careful
what nick boson nick bosa
[Laughter]
yeah january 8th was the day i found out
i was diagnosed so january 17th i must
have just been like [ __ ] sulking like
welcome home love you who is nick bosa
he's a defensive lineman for the san
francisco 49ers
a defensive lineman he's hella good
second overall
yeah i'm sure he's great yeah can we
just have you read these so yeah i
thought this was you gaining weight in
rehab
qualify that when was this and what was
that story do you remember december 12th
uh i think he was
he must have shown a pic of him like in
the weight room or something like that
looking bigger or no he was uh he had an
injury and uh you guys are just staring
at me i just i love this i [ __ ] love
it
this has got the ben foot pick same
energy yeah this is insane he got uh he
was like he must have been like a
shirtless picture of him i think he's
looking bigger for sure so and so
you said i saw this i thought this was
you gaining weight in rehab wishing you
well friend
but after rehab he has like a sweaty
smiling emoji yeah which
yeah yeah to me implies like you're
almost horny yeah i thought this was you
gaining weight in rehab you said horde
right yes
it's gonna get worse there's a josh
allen that's like gushy no no no so then
you follow up yeah i say so i said
welcome home baby get healthy 49er for
life please because he wanted to tell us
not even fully i wanted him to sign a
contract extension because i want him to
be a 49er for life
oh yeah
and you put [ __ ] hearts in it too
which is just crazy and then and then
that's when he signed his extension
let's go
money time i know you did that for me
there's even worse ones yeah let's let's
please keep
keep going does your does tatiana know
you do this
what does she say about this she doesn't
i don't know what is she supposed to say
oh dude i want to meet this guy so bad
this is a quarterback for the san
francisco 49ers troy lance trey lance uh
i said can't wait to watch you ball
cause we just drafted him that was i'm
assuming draft day that was not bad yeah
thank you
uh and then the other one he was wearing
an la dodgers hat and uh you know giants
fans you know
hate the dodgers so i said oh we're in
that giant's hat now i see
with the with the color with the color
of the giants
all right it gets better so it's funny
that's why i brought this others like
hella athletes follow you guys and i'm
like
you guys don't even follow them back
here we go josh allen is this the horny
one this is the horny oh there's a lot
oh this is my favorite player
yeah i'm wearing his jersey this was
super bowl day you are a [ __ ]
groupie
you are a group i'm a huge sports fan
[Laughter]
you are a groupie
you deserve it man
you deserve it grant cohen sucks
jesus christ
and then there's one way what is he
supposed to say to that i don't know bro
just like i agree like yeah your heart
it just heart it just
i just wanted him to just tap it double
tap that'll be good this is my favorite
to josh allen quarterback of the buffalo
bills
oh
zach
unscent that go into your bone no
no actually yeah no
keep it
it's not even cause it's like it's not
because it's homoerotic or anything
it's just like please be my friend
and that it reeks it gives
it's giving please be my friend would
you would you dm a ufc athlete like if
he was like in your area or if you like
i wouldn't go um yes
[Music]
oh no
i was just joking around
he doesn't know you like
he doesn't know you joe he doesn't know
who you are he follows casey frey and a
bunch of other people so i figured you
know maybe he's he knows the circle we
got to put this we got to cut this out
and put it in the free episode yeah just
so that like there's a chance that some
of these guys will see that oh and oh
and
absolutely who follows us george kittle
all right george who george kittle
george kittle is a message for you we
heard you got a tight end
and zach loves it that oh he did he only
follows cody zach just beat testicular
cancer all right
yeah he also um
like [ __ ] just like [ __ ]
and
he got fired yeah so actually don't dm
him just send him some clothes
son of your jersey yeah yeah
damn dude he said he sends him his
jersey and then he [ __ ] takes a
picture of it in the mirror just with no
shorts
just like the jersey with no pants and
he's like got it he
yes thanks george
yes josh yes george
yes so
what did you think of the whole jared
goff thing did you see that yeah and
what did you think of that that was sick
what was that what was that he got to
talk with jared goff
oh
so he cody like two cody pretended that
or pretended that you knew him or no you
pretended that you didn't know him you
never met him before but yeah we'll send
you like the video i've watched i've
watched it before but i thought the
whole thing was you haven't met him or
thought that yeah you gaslit him yeah
that's what it was yes yes yeah and then
he and then you went on the pot or he
went on the podcast with you and then
you said like uh i faked it
yeah we're just like a huge fan of the
show by the way
a sports podcast sports podcast that is
a really good idea yeah you guys should
have one yeah yeah we'll see oh
it's a good idea i'm just still grabbing
them yeah but anyways oh uh jack harlow
follows you guys yes yeah yeah that one
but you guys don't what do you what
would you do oh no we follow him i'm
pretty sure you don't i do on the drive
on the spaceship up here i was uh
checking it out late i absolutely do we
definitely both followed you what would
you dm jack harlow right now
i loved your new album
what's uh what's what's another athlete
that you thought followed yeah i
followed him uh oh my bad
sorry um
who i would be jealous over yeah
uh christian mccaffrey
his girlfriend lives right next to me
see don't say that
no wonder they're not responding yeah
yeah seriously
bro i know where your girlfriend lives
in the dmv
yeah
i saw your girlfriend today
she looked good she looked good man nice
work haha
you deserve it
bet she gives it to you huh
dude your girlfriend lives right next to
my boss
they're on my run
yo does your girl eat ass
my girl
[Laughter]
zach sending [ __ ] wikipedia page
messages bro oh man
i love this neighbor
[Laughter]
hey neighbor
howdy neighbor you guys still live down
in
lb i live in long beach though how nice
yeah where are you west hollywood nice
yeah you like it yeah
uh
it's okay i mean i'm apartment living so
i got cockroaches oh yeah
i got something that can cure that yeah
you need a bug assault reach for the
skies partner
i don't i'm not gonna do that
if i if i bought you a shredder you
wouldn't use it what's the shredder it's
a it's a revolver that you put co2 into
and then you put um a
you load it it looks like what you load
into a cap gun but it's full of salt um
pockets and you just but you have to see
them it's not like a preventative
measure no yeah you have to see him yeah
okay i just hit him with a shoe
but this one's more this is sick yeah
i i shot a roach into two pieces with
this oh hell yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
no a roach dude roaches don't feel
shitty
neck
where's the shoe
roaches you could cut them in half and
they're like
they keep moving
you hit the [ __ ] out of them
yeah that is pretty cool one time i i
was making fun of peeta on twitter i was
like oh what do pita mfs do when they
have cockroaches in their house and they
replied to my tweet with a whole article
they're like you gotta put chili pepper
and you gotta like
line it up in your house
[Laughter]
damn zach i can't believe you're
thirsting over at leasing through your
dns
i'm not gonna stop either
i'm gonna
i love that no i love that i play
fantasy i play fantasy football and i'm
gonna tell them like every sunday like
dude you just got me so many points man
i love you so much yeah or [ __ ] you man
no i would never i don't do that you
don't do that i also have a fake twitter
account what is it uh
don't worry about it okay
but uh i uh we'll tweet out one shot
like that for my fake account and have
you ever stopped
have you been like received well by
okay no cool i get good engagement
though he does he has actually got a
profit yeah wow he has eight thousand
tweets on it
i have three thousand tweets on my main
one i have eight thousand tweets on my
side account god i [ __ ] love it and i
said 50 51 followers on if on the side
again if there's anything we could hope
to do from this it's to get all of these
dudes
to can we recap my day so uh fired
jobless cancer and cancer uh substitute
teacher mm-hmm and she's dressed off in
front of your dad jacked off
behind closed doors
uh
and sperm banking and um
thirsting over athletes yeah